president I'm so ashamed that our kids
have to be raised in error what the
president is so ugly
what's uglier than swaddling a newborn
baby placing it into a crib in the next
room and then discussing whether you
kill it or not name me one thing that
Donald Trump has ever done including
grabbing all of them that would be as
ugly as that all right so I think this
goes back to the question the day come
on move into I think the left's really
it's just infanticide yeah their agenda
I think the abortion mask right now is
is slipping it's done yeah it's gone
it's gone honey lunch is gone I think
what's important up to in the past and
we've talked about this we did that
video with Abby Johnson former director
of planetary which was immediately
demonetised surprise civil long-form
discussion god no money at all
no profanity just we don't like your
opinion in the past the Planned
Parenthood message was that the abortion
it only made up about 3% of their
seriousness remember that recent
BuzzFeed puff piece though on the newest
CEO I think wasn't evenly Lyana when
they had headlined about Planned
Parenthood focusing on non abortion
services and Leon Owen then contradicted
it corrected them with a tweet claiming
that abortion was quote their core
mission basically just confirming what
we already knew right surprise this guy
is blue this is really important people
to note the safe legal and rare has gone
out the window and if you look at the
pills from we'll get into them in a
second the pills from New York now as
the bill in Virginia and theirs is their
six or seven proposed bills in in Rhode
Island Brautigan I think we're up think
it's up to seven okay there are quite a
few and they're just as bad so I think a
few points to keep in context here
Democrats and I mean the DNC platform
let's not talk about well you don't want
to generalize main and then extreme
right no no the DNC the Democratic
platform they are pushing abortion up
until birth don't believe me here's
delegate Kathy Kathy is a trans man
Kathy Tran talking specifically about
the abortion bill interstate so the way
the suggestion that we've made in the
bill is to say it's in the third
trimester and at the you know with the
certification of the physician or
perform an abortion if he indicated it
would impair the mental health of the of
the woman good question into physical
okay okay I'm talking about the mental
health it's really really so it means I
through the third trimester the third
trimester goes all the way up to 40
weeks okay but to the end of the third
trimester I don't think we have a limit
in the bill that means a baby by the way
we're not talked about a clump of cells
we're not talking as I goats she's
saying mental she tries to this is what
happens right she tries to redirect it
well or physical healthy goes okay but
there's also mental health we agree on
physical health if a mom is going to die
at that point of both beings are going
to die obviously you take the lesser of
two evils in that scenario I understand
it as a reasonable argument I won't get
into that right now but the broader
exception is mental health yeah what
about mental health I'd be like going in
for a mortgage or gonna it's gonna be a
three percent rate do percent no no ha a
second that's not how this works you're
just gonna say a word and she refuses to
say a baby it's up until it comes out of
the birth canal yeah it's like a any
reason by the way it can mean anything
mental oh it's like a medical marijuana
card only was killing a baby yeah I have
that pain I don't like the baby I think
he's gonna be yeah approved yeah and
that's what people think like oh my gosh
it's gonna be this refined process no
there are doctors out there that want to
be at advocates for this and activists
essentially and they're gonna do it for
whatever reason right we're gonna see
economic health pretty soon here right
that's right that's the third thing that
we're gonna see I can't afford this it's
about two weeks until the baby's due can
you please help me right really people
say would you really think it's going to
get that extreme well okay when we went
to the next point but considering that
smiling is now seen as the sign of white
supremacy there's like well you're not
supporting the welfare state that's what
you promise me I don't really think so
but okay you want to use some
demographics and say that it's a
discriminatory toward minorities all
right voting for Donald Trump is racist
really think that's the case smiling is
like the KKK yeah how quickly do you
think it will devolve here on the left
when it comes to abortion I don't know
how much further they can devolve here
this brings us to our next point
Democrats by the way are pushing for
abortion even after birth so that's
murder you'll just have to burn there
will be blood it's no one here away
Lord here's a new governor Ralph is it
pronounced Northam north ham no no and
basically endorsing infanticide
thank God we videotape radio interviews
now let's play this when we talk about
3rd trimester abortions these are done
with the consent of obviously that the
mother with the consent of the
physicians more than one physician by
the law and it's done in cases where
there may be severe deformities there
may be a fetus that's non-viable so in
this particular I can tell you exactly
what would happen the infant would be
delivered the infant would be kept
comfortable the infant would be
resuscitated if that's what the mother
and the family desires and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mother so so I think
this was really blown out of proportion
it was what happened to non-viable yeah
he literally says non-viable in the
first half and says by the way then we
might necessitate the baby feed it but
give it a feeding make sure that it's
alive and then leave it to die as we
have a discussion yeah what kind of a
discussion say okay listen you have a
baby right now who's been swallowing
blankets it's in the next room we'd like
to see what kind of options you'd like
to discuss including our tiny caskets
special for only five you only have half
an hour to act though it really is
remarkable
road trips to the northern famous have
been really interesting kids if you
don't shut up a discussion will ensue
all right listen I'm gonna turn this car
around have a discussion with you even
the Adams family would look at this and
say god on me that's if there's the
slightest silver lining in people saying
that we should kill literally kill kill
people if this wakes people up with a
pay more attention to issues because
I've noticed a lot of a lot of a
political friends in New York are
expressing their disgust of the New York
bill yeah I'm gonna go on a limb that
their voters in Virginia who consider
themselves to be pro-life but voted for
the governor just because orange man bad
sure hopefully now they could people are
waking up and you know there are worse
things and Donald Trump being on Twitter
any
killing baby that's why I hate the whole
discussion of let's find common ground
let's meet in the middle Oh Hall in a
second this is the National Democratic
platform guys right this isn't some
extremists isn't the Young Turks this
isn't Samantha bee this is what all of
the Democrats who when they form state
legislature this is what they want this
is what they have and by the way is this
a shock it shouldn't be concerned that
Democrats have repeatedly voted against
measures like the born alive Protection
Act which protected babies after they
were born alive it's in the name Barack
Obama didn't vote president he voted no
this has been the mo of those in power
for a long time by the way it's just
they haven't had it completely
unfettered and if you want to know what
it looks like just look at New York yeah
and this could basically single-handedly
give the election over to Donald Trump I
really don't know why this issue is
coming out in force like it is right now
because we're about two years before the
presidential cycle sorry about two years
before the election so the cycle
starting yeah people are gonna start
going out you're seeing it with
Democrats saying they're gonna throw
their hats in the ring if this issue is
on the table and that bill they don't
get what they are so a tone-deaf we
pulled this story from huffington post
okay and a headline it was something
like tucker carlson gets burned in his
own show and he asked this liberal guest
he says okay you saw this from from
northern right here yeah what do you
think about this i think you want to
take us back to overturning roe v wade
he goes no I don't want to do that but
can can we not throw talking points can
you please talk about this which was on
tape today I wanna talk about how you
have no say what women do with their
bodies Huffington Post watch this exact
same video and they see it as a win they
put that one up on the scoreboard for
themselves speaking of wins by the way
hit the notification bell if you're
subscribed because apparently doesn't
mean a whole lot on YouTube and it might
get lost in subscription box join my
club ninety nine dollars annually six
nine for students veterans active
military letters credit that come slash
mug Club you get the full daily showing
it's what supports the content also
iTunes if you're listening to the audio
version here's what's also really
important enough that abortion up until
birth it's it's not a far left position
I cannot reiterate that enough this guy
he's not Cortez he's he's seen as a
centrist
okay never didn't available is defeated
but New York just passed the but the
bill is passed
yeah and now I think Rhode Island I
think it's someone can correct me it's
either seven or six bills proposed in
Rhode Island this is important to know
this is mainstream leftism so when
people say all you know there's such a
stark contrast between all these
Democratic candidates in Donald Trump
sure
yeah I'm okay with that right you all
want to kill babies up to 40 weeks and
after 40 weeks good there's there's
enough of a contrast and this is the
thing for me right now this is where you
draw the line I know yesterday we were
talking a little bit about some finding
some common ground educating people this
is not that issue necessarily now when
you start to say that you're okay with
third trimester you go out of your way
to make it physical health instead of
mental health of this gigantic loophole
that you know people are gonna run
through you have absolutely revealed
what your strategy is and one thing that
you don't want to do people dislike
Donald Trump but they are so pro-life
that they will get out and vote for him
here's what's really important the left
is lying in order to turn get this
legislation passed they said well most
Americans are pro-choice
okay we're using the term pro-choice but
the the American public are
overwhelmingly against abortion up until
birth as opposed by 80% or so most
Americans don't support third trimester
abortions the Democratic platform does
yeah this is crazy to me to present such
a big deal out of Trump insulting people
about being notes being rude or ugly I'm
so ashamed you know kids have to be
raised in the era where the president is
so ugly
what's uglier than swaddling a newborn
baby placing it into a crib in the next
room and then discussing whether you
kill it or not name me one thing that
Donald Trump has ever done including
grabbing all of the box that will be as
ugly as that stormy Oh stormy Daniels
that's bad okay that's fine I stand
corrected
and you to the advocates is something is
really important it's just inaccurate
this is one of those issues where the
further we advanced scientifically the
less ground they have to stand on they
make this claim that third trimester
abortions only necessary in some rare
circumstances when the baby is gonna die
anyway no it's that's not what's
actually happening the Guttmacher
Institute which by the way
pro-choice pro-abortion Organization
says that the data shows quote most
women seeking later term abortions are
not doing so for reasons of fetal
anomaly or life endangerment Wow but
it's right there and then I thought I
thought we had medical procedures for
this if the baby's life was in danger if
mom's life was in danger and going to
term with this I thought we had
c-sections yeah I thought that was part
of the issue saying hey this is
dangerous let's do this by the way do
you know there's story after story after
story right now in the media that people
who are alive 20 years later saying my
the doctor told my mom
was not Bible right and I I made it out
fine she's fine this isn't an exact
science with these guys there's a huge
lane to drive I just want for sure so
geographically dependent oh wait a
second a baby in the hills of Virginia
not not Virginia but West Virginia's
gothe West Virginia the heels of
Kentucky right baby is it is that life
worth less than the baby in a hospital
in Lenox Hill in the Upper East Side
simply because they have access to
better medical viability is not a
consistent argument what's crazy what
are we supposed to find common ground
here this is what's great there's no
common ground left oh ho let's find
common ground on plan B okay let's do it
now now how about second trimester what
we're supposed to find now up until
birth if it's born can we kill it
remember common ground common ground and
they want to call you an extremist puck
safe legal and rare was supposed to be
the common ground for a long time rape
incest health of the mother that was
supposed to be common I just said health
I like trigger model the hill health
Murrah the mother not mental health and
this is so what's so funny to me they
said this have Christians for a long
time right these two say oh there's
single-issue voters they're morons or
single-issue voters if you're gonna be a
single-issue voter what's more important
hating Donald Trump because you think
he's a dick or not killing live babies
imagine looking back through history and
saying man the out the Allies in World
War two were really single issue guys
Abraham Lincoln was a single issue dick
here's the thing yes I understand
obviously the economy matters if you're
looking at an election trade whatever
but if there are still people who are
being enslaved against their will then
that is the only issue it's just like if
you cover somebody's mouth and pinch
their nose then all of a sudden you call
him an oxygen extremist issue
their only issue that matters at point
is oxygen right and all the single issue
voting was justified we knew it it was
never going to stop at Hobby Lobby
providing what was it they provided 16
out of the 20 or 21 forms of birth
control and they were saying no Hassan
and they have to be mandated to provide
all 21 forms of birth control that was
never going to be the endpoint the
endpoint was never going to be the plan
bill Plante Plan B uh pill their plan
was always to push it this far and by
the way how is this not straight up evil
purposefully evil I think that people
can be used as tools of evil have talked
about burrow
go bomb with this I don't think Barack
Obama proactively went out and said I'm
going to subvert the cause of good right
I'm an evil person but I think he was
used as a tool for evil certainly if you
look at his voting record specifically
on this issue but with this it's not
someone who's being used as a tool
without knowing it free
they are proactively killing babies they
are walking into the room knowing fully
what their mission is to kill a baby
that's it they don't care and this is
what's so funny we could say like oh
this is one point is the path to use in
a euthanasia right of their of children
but this slippery slope is an argument
there is no more slope there is no more
path we're done we're at the end of the
path that's it here I'm going to make a
bold statement here what Hitler did is
no more evil than this he just did it
more times are you are you saying that
yes yes I believe that aborting a baby
at 40 weeks at 25 it's 30 at 35 weeks
certainly after it's born I believe that
is every bit as evil as what Hitler did
yeah you think you think it's an extreme
example to make a point it's two of the
biggest states in the Union are you okay
with this you're okay with babies being
born alive dying because that's where we
are now it's that one okay I'm okay with
this but hold on a second we're past all
other considerations there is no more
slope there is no more slide there is no
more path we're here that's the final
question are you pro-life okay or are
you Pro this what's this delivering a
newborn wrapping it in a blankie and
then leaving it to die that's what's
happening that's what's happening right
now legally that's what the legislation
is pushing for period there's no more
path there's no more slope to slip this
is where we are are you pro-life or are
you Pro this that's it find common
ground on that if you like this video
subscribe to the channel or hit the
notification bell do it I'll wait a
second do you hear that little ding it
actually didn't make a ding sound I just
did it would happen while my mouth was
doing it and you thought it was coming
from your computer so that's fun also
there's some videos playing in these
boxes next to me go watch those you
might enjoy them you might not you don't
care